et quand on cherche en petits morceaux
doit on oublier de ce mouvement tout le
reste tout commence pour le vrai puzzle
en bois par le contreplaqué conçu
spécialement pour l'entreprise de
nichane wilson contreplaqué de 3 mm
d'épaisseur du peuplier les
reproductions aux photos ont été achetés
dans les musées le louvre orsay picasso
cluny la bibliothèque nationale les arts
déco l'institut du monde arabe ou bien
la comédie française entre autres on
prend donc la dimension on colle le
modèle où le clis et on découpe à la
main en cinq exemplaires
il croit dans votre album des couleurs
on nous coupe les changements continuent
la pièce sera pas découpé comme on veut
et puis on découpe aussi en cédant leurs
copains et les personnages et chaque
découpeuse à sa propre technique c'est
bien tout et de la découpe est créé son
morceau à chaque fois on est dessiné à
la base ce sens selon son inspiration
vincent fait cinq questions puisque des
couples épaisse par cinq la fois 5e même
dans les sujets ni formation découpe
puis traîné morceau michel wilson a crû
de 3,6 modèle chaufferie duriez aussi
les collections les 25 pièces au 5500
que vous trouverez ici seulement à
bourgogne très près de tournus ou bien à
paris à la boutique c'est elle qui pour
la première fois en 1975 présente un
catalogue avec les modèles
dans le monde du pulse qu'on nous
parlait effectivement nombre de morceaux
ainsi aujourd'hui d'ailleurs pour la
production aussi en parler
on découpe mille morceaux à l'heure l'an
dernier 2 millions de morceaux du
exportations avec sa belgique allemagne
grande-bretagne clients la plupart nous
intellectuels du talent des artistes à
paris comme annie girardot fut michel
boujenah mais le vrai vrai amateur lui
choisira des sujets donné pas mal de
pièces et puis vraiment à son poste il
dépassera 2 heures et des heures jour
même des nuits même
tout jeu
de sannine qu'elle ne le commande six
mois la balance et quand elle voit ou
que son peu comment ça se termine elle
n'appelle vraiment catastrophe attention
il était hors de mon peuple d'une vitre
mais telle autre chantier à ne peut pas
supporter d'être simple ça c'est des
vrais mobiles raconte défaut
orange dans une armoire
ce qui se vend le mieux les classiques
les peintres impressionnistes ou les
gravures hong lei